El sexto palestino fallecido como
consecuencia de los enfrentamientos de
ayer en jenín fue identificado como un
hombre de 48 años que murió en la
madrugada a causa de las heridas sin
embargo con casi un centenar de heridos
palestinos algunos de gravedad cabe
esperar que esta cifra de Muertos pueda
volver a aumentar recordemos que los
choques se iniciaron a raíz de una
redada de las fuerzas israelíes en esa
área del norte de Jordania ocupada en el
operativo detuvieron a dos personas y
usaron un helicóptero de la fuerza aérea
algo que no ocurría desde hace casi dos
décadas el ejército israelí dijo que
apeló a esto para evacuar a sus soldados
heridos tras el estallido de un
artefacto explosivo fueron ocho los
oficiales lastimados que recibieron la
visita del Primer Ministro Benjamín
netaniagu tras el hecho desde nada más
radical del gobierno Israel se han
incrementado los pedidos para lanzar una
operación militar a gran escala en el
norte de sijordania una opción Que de
momento y según medios israelíes los
altos en mandos militares no recomiendan
por su parte desde la autoridad medicina
condenaron la redada israelí en cherín
que la tildaron de masacre un rechazo al
que se sumó Egipto que acusó a Israel de
escalar la violencia a esta redada le
sucedieron otros dos hechos marcando así
una de las jornadas más violentas en si
Jordania ocupada en 2023 horas después
de la incursión dos soldados israelíes
resultaron levemente heridos en un
supuesto atropello intencional al igual
que los dos ocupantes del vehículo
alcanzados por los disparos de soldados
posteriormente en usan en el área de
Belén un joven de 20 años murió horas
después de recibir disparos de las
fuerzas israelíes durante unos
disturbios que dejaron también otros dos
heridos